hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and asta is gone
lucius was telling the truth osta was in
fact eliminated as a threat
at least for now asta was apparently
isaki'ed to another world with his
grimoire and he is so far away that no
one can sense his presence any longer he
may be on another continent or maybe
even in another dimension
and here's the crazy part wherever hosta
has been teleported to
someone is there and expecting him
what's more we may never see the old
osta again because i believe that austin
liebe are about to resurrect the time
devil asteroth
and when asta does return to the clover
kingdom to face lucius he will do it in
a completely new form with completely
new magic before we get into it quick
warning about scammers in the comments
if you watch my other videos you've
probably heard this already but i just
want to warn everyone not to trust
scammers in the comments offering
giveaways and telling you to follow them
on telegram and other apps we do not use
telegram and if there is ever a giveaway
here on the channel we will mention it
directly in the video we're not just
gonna mention it in the comments i try
to ban these cameras from the channel
whenever i see them but unfortunately
they keep popping up because they're
bots so please be careful if you're not
a bot be sure to leave a like and
subscribe to the channel to help us out
with the youtube algorithm and of course
this video will of course contain black
hover manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned the
previous chapter ended on a massive
cliffhanger osta's injured body suddenly
disappeared after being hit with a
spatial magic spell launched by sister
lily at the same time lucius boldly
declared that asta has been eliminated
which instantly made us think that asta
could have been killed well not really
he is the protagonist and this is black
clover but the question of what really
happened to osta loomed large over the
fandom and the concern over asta's fate
was amplified by all the shocked and
terrified expressions on those who care
about him including noel mimosa secret
and others the answer of what really
happened to osta was revealed in the
very next chapter but more on that in a
little bit the latest chapter begins
after some time has already passed after
hosta's disappearance sister lily and
lucius used spatial magic to teleport
out of harm's way and so the captains
never got the chance to fight lucius
after that the news that the wizard king
is actually a villain began to trickle
out all over the clover kingdom and once
uno returns from his trip he quickly
meets with the magic knight captains and
other powerful allies in order to
discuss what happens next yuno is
understandably furious when he learns
about the wizard king's betrayal and
asta's sudden disappearance and some of
the captains begin having doubts about
their ability to challenge lucius for
example real says that if lucius really
was able to subjugate all the supreme
devils from the underworld then what
chance do they have of defeating him
their struggle against lucius may be
hopeless at the same time they're all
still trying to figure out what happened
to asta noct explains that he can move
into the shadow of any person he chooses
at will
but right now he cannot enter osta's
shadow in order to locate him this can
mean only one of two things either osta
really is dead or he is extremely far
away so far away that knocked cannot
locate him with his shadow magic but
this doesn't mean that he's just like in
the next town over or something like
that it means that he must be on another
continent or in another dimension in
other words he is incredibly far away
now in terms of lucius's power it is
clear that he is by far the strongest
enemy that the clover kingdom has ever
faced not only does he have supreme
devils like adramelech under his command
he also controls the magic of the
supreme devils from the underworld he
also has a bunch of other high ranked
devils under his control and he has two
types of absolutely overpowered magic
time magic and soul magic using soul
magic lucius can manipulate a person's
soul which seems to include their magic
and their mind and to make things worse
the good guys only have 7 days to
prepare for lucius's judgment day you
yuno then steps up to the plate in order
to rally the troops and rekindle their
hope of victory he says that if foster
is dead and he is never coming back then
yuno will become the one who will
surpass the wizard king and speaking of
the wizard king we see adramelech
approaching a throne on top of which
lucius is sitting off to lucius's right
side we see sister lily and damnatio
kira which means that both of them have
now been turned into his paladins
there are two other people standing to
the left of lucius but their entire
bodies are covered in shadow and so we
can't determine who they are adramelech
says that he is genuinely surprised by
how strong yuno has gotten in only a
year yuno is now able to kill an entire
group of high-ranking devils in an
instant and with his two grimars and the
power of leaked son and self
yuno is the only remaining threat to
lucius's ultimate master plan
lucius says that in all of the tens of
thousands of predictions that he had
access to thanks to time magic there is
only one future in which his enemies
have the upper hand and the key to that
specific future is yuno himself and so
at the same time that yuno vows to
defeat lucius and become the wizard king
lucius vows to crush yuno for the sake
of world peace
the final section of the chapter finally
reveals what really happened to asta he
has been teleported to a sandy beach and
he is lying motionless alongside his
grimoire
as osta just lies there a man approaches
him and says oh there you are as if he
was expecting asta to show up here we
cannot see what this person looks like
because the upper part of their body is
completely hidden in shadow but by the
style of the outfit that the person is
wearing we can conclude that he is from
the land of the rising sun aka hino
country the mysterious homeland of
captain yami and that is how this
chapter ends with the confirmation that
asta is still alive but he has been
teleported extremely far away
so when lucius said that asta was
eliminated he didn't mean that asta was
killed he meant that asta is now so far
away that he has been eliminated as a
threat but even though this chapter
answered the question of what happened
to osta by doing that it also raised a
whole bunch of new questions
why was asta teleported to yami's
homeland and why is there someone there
who was actually expecting him could
this man have some sort of previous
connection to asta like could he be
asta's biological father or is he maybe
there to train asta in order to prepare
him for the final fight against lucius
was sister lily even supposed to
teleport him here or did someone
intervene in order to ensure that asta
would be teleported to this exact spot
where someone was waiting for him oh and
by the way where is the land of the
rising sun anyway we know almost nothing
about it so is it just another continent
in the world of black clover or could it
be another dimension altogether as
knocked subtly hinted at earlier years
ago i did a video in which i theorized
that hino country could be a different
dimension maybe even medieval japan in
our own world and when yami accidentally
traveled from his homeland to the clover
kingdom he didn't just travel from one
continent to another but from one
dimension to another knowing asta and
how the man never gives up one would
think that lucius would know that being
on another continent would absolutely
not stop asta from coming back even
stronger than before but if lucius
thought that he had sent osta all the
way to another dimension and somewhere
that asta can't return from then his
actions would make more sense as well as
his comment that asta has been
eliminated what do you guys think is
hino country just another continent or
is it another dimension altogether why
was there someone expecting asta in that
exact location in that exact time could
this man be asta's father or is he maybe
related to yami is this connected to the
fact that aston yami appear to be the
only two people who can sense ki in the
world of black clover like is that
ability unique to the people from hino
country and since asta's biological
father might actually be from there osta
happens to have that same ability also
why would lucius think that hino country
is a good place to teleport asta instead
of like into space or something was this
the intended location or did someone
interfere with the teleportation spell
definitely comment down below what your
thoughts are because as i said this
chapter did answer some important
questions but it raised even more
questions immediately after that i think
that whatever happens next with austin
liebe will be directly connected to the
time devil asteroth and in my previous
black clover video i talked at length
about the connection that i think austin
liba have to the supreme time devil i
believe that austin liebe are two halves
of asteroth and that someone possibly
julius split asteroth's soul from his
magic and then divided that soul into
two pieces in order to create osta the
only human born without magic and liebe
the only devil born without magic
together astan liba became the ultimate
secret weapon for defeating lucius but
in order to truly destroy him they will
need to rediscover their true nature
they will have to form the perfect devil
union which will resurrect asteroth
himself
this resurrection will create asta and
libis final form the ultimate
transformation of two halves of one soul
into the single supreme time devil
asteroth and in the previous few videos
that i've been talking about this theory
i noticed that you guys really enjoyed
it and you left a whole bunch of really
great comments that build on this theory
and make it even better for example i
mentioned the idea that time magic and
anti-magic could combine in some way to
create a new ultimate magic that will
defeat lucius a few of you guys
commented saying that anti-magic itself
could be a byproduct of time magic the
idea is that anti-magic isn't
necessarily its own independent force
but rather it actually just cancels out
the magic of others by stopping or even
reversing the time of those spells this
would make anti-magic a sort of dark or
negative counterpart of time magic and
once both of these powers are reunited
within one devil asteroth it will
transform into an absolutely overpowered
new magic type i do think that this is
an interesting idea but we would have to
account for the fact that anti-magic
also seems to be able to absorb the
magic of others such as when asta is
using the demon dweller sword and the
demon destroyer sword that doesn't seem
to be an effect that is directly related
to time so this would have to be
accounted for in order for this
anti-magic as the other side of time
magic theory to be true another
fascinating comment that i saw was
talking about the symbol on osta's
headband and the fact that this symbol
looks a lot like the symbol that is
visible inside the time magic orbs when
someone uses time magic i agree that the
symbols look very similar although
asta's symbol almost looks like it's an
incomplete version and the symbol inside
the time orbs looks like it might be the
complete version of the shape on asta's
headband this could suggest an
additional connection between time magic
and asta's anti-magic but it is quite
subtle so we can't say with any
certainty whether this is an intentional
clue or whether it's just an artistic
style i personally lean towards the idea
that yes tabata is hinting at a hidden
connection a connection that links back
to the time devil asteroth but we still
can't prove anything at this point in
time additionally i also saw multiple
comments across several videos
mentioning osta's horns including the
fact that he manifests a fifth horn in
his devil union form since liebe only
has two horns in his base form these
extra horns could be a clue that asta is
part devil himself or rather that he is
one half of asteroth since asteroth is a
supreme devil and one of the three
strongest devils and since the strongest
devils tend to have more than two horns
and their horns tend to be larger and
more impressive maybe when asta and
liber come together in their devil union
form asteroth's true horns begin to
manifest and there appear to be five of
them eventually these horns may get
larger and more impressive as austin
libi's devil union becomes more perfect
and as asteroth's true nature begins to
manifest and if this theory is true i am
just so fascinated to find out what
asteroth's true form will look like and
also what his personality will be like
as well i am super interested to see why
asteroth went missing from the
underworld and why we haven't seen him
yet in the story since time magic gives
lucius the ability to look at like tens
of thousands of possible future
scenarios and plan accordingly i can
only imagine how many future scenarios
asteroth himself was able to anticipate
using his own original magic time magic
i wonder if astaroth anticipated that
lucius would find a way to subjugate all
the other supreme devils so he
deliberately orchestrated his escape
from the underworld perhaps even with
the help of julius and that is because
he wanted to avoid being placed under
lucius's control later in the future
this would mean that asteroth may have
played an active role in the creation of
asta and liebe and in everything that is
about to happen next in the story
honestly i can't wait to see the
introduction or maybe the resurrection
of asteroth the potential fusion of time
magic and anti-magic and the final
showdown between asteroth and lucius i
mean what would a fusion of time magic
and anti-magic even look like maybe
something like eddie's quirk from mha
where asta can rewind people's magic out
of existence or something like that i
don't know but definitely let me know
down in the comments what you think a
fusion of time magic and anti-magic
would look like and what kind of
abilities this new absolutely broken
magic type could possibly have also do
you think that once asteroth is
resurrected he will be a sort of mixture
of asta and leave his personality or
would he be a completely different
personality or would he just be like a
berserker who wants to destroy all his
enemies and who can't be controlled by
anyone i really want to hear what you
guys think as i said earlier the comment
sections have been on fire lately and
this really inspires me to keep making
more videos if you're looking for a
video to watch next check out that video
from last week where i explained why
astan liebig could be two halves of
asteroth's soul link in the description
if you enjoy our black over content and
you want to see more in the future leave
a like and comment right now it only
takes a second but it really helps us
with that youtube algorithm and if you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications the way that youtube works
you really have to go through the
trouble of subscribing hitting the bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys